the slow burn monstrous horror of
midnight mass and its chilling story of
angels demons guilt and redemption leads
to an explosive ending that will leave
you thinking about the show long after
it's finished yipikai movie lovers i'm
jan and in this video i'm explaining
everything about the ending of midnight
mass some crucial details you might have
missed and why that final scene doesn't
quite mean what you think it does
obviously spoilers ahead so take care
to fully understand the fiery finale we
need to go back to the origin of the
miracles and mysteries that occur on
crockett island after father paul
arrives paul as we discover in the third
episode is actually the island's
original priest the elderly monsignor
john pruitt who's been transformed into
his younger self after a pilgrimage to
jerusalem during his trip one day pruitt
was separated from his group and ended
up outside the city wandering on the
road to damascus as a sandstorm hit he
sought shelter in a cave where he was
attacked by a winged vampire who bit his
neck and began to consume his blood
before the priest died though the
creature pierced its own skin and fed
his blood to pruitt this is my blood
shed for you and for all so that sins
may be forgiven these words are from the
last supper and are a crucial part of
the catholic mass and doctrine which
states that the bread and wine offered
during communion become the actual body
and blood of christ by saying this about
pruitt receiving the creature's blood
paul shows that he believes it's a holy
sacrament equivalent to the blood of
christ pruitt believed it was an angel
notice the halo which he sees form
around its head paul calls the wound the
creature makes on its wrist to stigmata
referencing the wounds inflicted on
jesus when he was crucified also notice
that the wood carvings illustrating
pruitt's experience are numbered from 1
to 14 in roman numerals a nod to the
stations of the cross images often found
in churches which depict the events of
jesus's crucifixion and death when
pruitt awakened he decided to take the
name paul in reference to saul who
became paul when he experienced a
life-changing event on the road from
jerusalem to damascus that converted him
to one of christianity's most renowned
apostles similar to saul father paul
believes it's his duty to spread the
miracle of what happened to him to the
whole world and he begins by smuggling
the vampire back to crockett island in a
trunk on the island paul begins to add
the creature's blood to the communion
wine and little by little those who take
communion find their physical ailments
slipping away riley's mother no longer
needs glasses and his father's back gets
better even more miraculously the
paralyzed lisa finds she can now walk
while sarah gunning's mother mildred
regains her mental faculties and begins
to de-age incredibly
after a while on the island paul starts
to feel sick then suddenly keels over
and dies a few minutes later he comes
back to life however he now discovers
that exposure to sunlight burns his skin
he's also no longer interested in
regular food his body instead craving
human blood which leads to joe colley's
death and paul's next bloody meal later
paul discusses with riley whether he
felt any remorse for his part in joe's
death and justifies his lack of guilt by
quoting something beverly showed him in
the bible the graces of the holy spirit
rained down on me cleansed my conscience
for i had simply done his will the
priests appealed to the bible as
justification for his actions shows how
misguided he's become and is a warning
about those who use religion as a reason
to justify terrible behavior and
atrocities by contrast riley
demonstrates the ability to avoid giving
in to temptation when he goes out on the
boat with erin riley's resistance here
matches his own struggle with alcohol
addiction and how he genuinely felt
culpable and remorseful and took
responsibility for the death of the girl
he killed in the car accident you
struggled with what happened that's what
i did paul however twists his religion
to suit his own purposes while making
out that he's somehow doing god's will
and together with the wickedly
holier-than-thou beverly keane puts into
action a terrible final plan for the
easter vigil at the midnight mass
beverly distributes cups with a lethal
poison while paul urges everyone to
drink so they can die and be reborn let
your earthly body die so that your
divine body can awaken anyone who's
already taken communion since paul's
arrival on the island will have drunk
some of the angels blood and so will
resurrect soon after dying in the
chaotic events that follow the reborn
vampires attack any still-living humans
as they try to flee the church the
events of the vigil bring to mind the
real world jonestown massacre in 1978
when members of the people's temple cult
committed mass suicide after their
leader jim jones exhorted everyone to
drink a poison-laced kool-aid-like drink
the blood bath at the church spills out
onto the rest of the island with bev
encouraging the newborn vampires to kill
or convert anyone left she orders every
building burned so there'll be no refuge
come sunrise except for the church and
rec center and she sets herself up as
the moral arbiter of who's worthy to be
allowed in and who should perish in the
sunlight by this point paul has reunited
with mildred who's been reborn after
being killed by the angel and he
confesses that his real reason for
bringing the angel to the island was
selfish as he wanted a second chance at
life with mildred and their daughter
sarah millie understands but counters
that his wish goes against the natural
order of things we lived our lives she
grew up and we faded away
and that's how it's supposed to work the
cost of his choice is stark as not only
has the vampire mob run riot on the
island but when paul finds his daughter
in the church about to burn it down
she's suddenly shot by sturge paul tries
to bring her back with his blood before
she dies but she spits it out rejecting
the cursed resurrection that would come
with it paul fully understands the
horror of the unnatural force he
unleashed and with millie burns down the
church the rec center goes up in flames
next thanks to sheriff hassan and aaron
who've doused it with petrol and
significantly it's ali who sets it
alight as like ed and annie flynn and
some of the others who turned into
vampires he's able to resist the urges
that come with it and he does what he
can to stop the ghoulish enterprise even
if it means his own death eren in the
meantime is attacked by the angel but as
it feeds on her she steadily slices the
creature's wings tearing large holes
into them so it can no longer fly
properly with the hope it won't be able
to reach the mainland 30 miles away
before sunrise this moment was
foreshadowed during her talk with riley
about how when eren was a child her
mother wanted to clip the wings of a
pair of pet doves so they wouldn't fly
away she said everyone gets their wings
clipped at some point with the wreck
center burning everyone except bev keen
accepts the fate that awaits them and
sturge owns up to the horrors he's
participated in and asks for forgiveness
will you forgive me kid i'll forgive you
paul too asks milly for forgiveness and
tosses his priest's collar away and as
the remaining islanders await the dawn
they sing the hymn nearer my god to thee
a song often associated with funerals
and which some of said was played on the
titanic as it sunk hassan and ali also
pray on the beach until a sand's
overcome by his wounds and his son burns
up beth keane refuses to give in right
to the bitter end as she tries to dig a
shelter in the sand before going up in
flames like everyone else it's ironic
that her second and final death is
burning to a crisp given how she decided
to burn down the island and what she
quoted from the book of revelation about
how true sinners would die as for the
cowardly their place will be in the lake
that burns which is the second death bev
of course was a huge hypocrite and
coward notice how at the easter vigil
she didn't drink the poison herself and
hid in the back of the building as the
others became vampires unlike the rest
of the islanders who find solace
together in their final moments she's
unable to accept responsibility for
what's to come and die screaming in
anger the only two people left alive by
the end are liza and warren riley's
younger brother they escaped the
massacre at the church without dying and
being resurrected as vampires so they're
able to survive the sunrise the very
last words of the finale eliza saying
that she can no longer feel her legs
meaning the healing effect of the angel
blood is worn off and she's paralyzed
again now initially i assumed this
implied the angel had died in the
sunrise however in an interview with the
rap the show's creator mike flanagan has
said that that's not exactly the case
although he seems to acknowledge that it
might be a valid interpretation of the
ending flanigan said that the reason
lisa was becoming paralyzed again was
because the concentration in their blood
had begun to tip back and that they
didn't want it to confirm about the
angel and that you can never kill
fanaticism it will always kind of come
back what flanagan is referring to about
the concentration in lisa's blood
tipping back is a scientific explanation
that the island's dr sarah gunning came
up with for what was going on with the
blood test she carried out sarah
discovered that erin and her mother's
blood only had relatively small amounts
of an active substance which she saw
burn up whenever it was exposed to
sunlight and she hypothesized that if
the amounts of this substance were small
enough in a person's body and they
stopped receiving any more of it they
would eventually excrete it from their
system when we ingest poison alcohol
whatever before a certain point if we
stop taking it in maybe our body can
push it back out this appears to be what
happened with lisa as now she's gone
some time without communion the effects
of the angel blood seem to be wearing
off hence the return of her paralysis by
the way if you want to know why father
paul was able to wander around in the
daylight for the first two episodes
without burning up it's because he never
actually died in the cave the angel gave
him blood to heal his wounds while he
was still alive and because he hadn't
died at that point and been reborn he
was able to move around in the daylight
according to flanagan this was part of
the angel's plan so that paul could help
the creature get out of the cave
flanagan also said that the reason for
paul's death in the third episode was
because he'd taken in too much of the
blood and it hit that critical mass that
sarah talks about what i think
flanagan's referring to is sarah's
explanation that the angel's blood is
like a virus a parasite or a poison of
sorts and that if it accumulates too
much it can kill you as a catholic
priest paul would be obliged to consume
all the leftover communion wine from
every mass so he'd likely be drinking
more of it than anyone else of course
flanagan's suggestion that the angel
isn't necessarily dead does leave the
potential for a follow-up second season
if we assume that it did reach the
mainland and find cover before the dawn
as bad as those cuts were the angel does
have the power of self-healing so
although it's a horrifying thought it
does leave the opportunity to pick up
this story again should flanagan want to
i want to thank the sponsor of this
video nordvpn an awesome vpn service
that keeps our online work and activity
private and secure you might not know
but many internet service providers keep
a record of all your online activity and
can even sell your data to third parties
and in some countries a wide range of
institutions can also access your
internet records without a warrant and
snoop on your browsing habits an easy
way to stop this is by using a virtual
private network whenever you're online a
vpn encrypts your connection and makes
your browsing history emails you send
and private messages unreadable to your
isp but using a free vpn can slow your
browsing down to such a snail's pace
that it feels the lifespan sucked out of
you much like the inhabitants of
crockett island however our experience
with nord at flicks in the city has been
great and we've always been able to get
blisteringly fast download and upload
speeds with the service nord has zero
bandwidth throttling plus a no log
policy so it doesn't record or retain
details of your online activity when
you're connected to its service for a
limited time nordvpn are offering all
our viewers a huge discount on a
two-year plan plus four months free just
visit
nordvpn.comflix or go to the link in the
video description to grab the offer or
use coupon code flicks when you check
out so what did you think of midnight
mass and how it ended and do you think
it's possible that the angel survived
leave your thoughts and theories in the
comments below if you enjoyed this and a
thumbs up and a share are hugely
appreciated and if you're a mike
flanagan fan tap left to check out all
the easter eggs and hidden ghosts in the
haunting of blind manor or tap right for
something else you're sure to like
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee guy movie lovers